former chairman of the House Oversight
Committee Fox News contributor jason
Chaffetz Fox News contributor
investigative reporter Sarah Carter Fox
News legal analyst Greg Jarrett
all right the Sarah let's let's go you
have broken some of this news tonight
you heard at the beginning that the DOJ
as we speak are recovering the missing
five months that is huge tonight
it's huge news and it fits with what
other FBI agents were telling me former
and current where they said look they
can get these text messages there is no
way there was a technical glitch that
got rid of all these text messages look
the FBI are experts at going after
criminals who try to hide their text
messages and they're able to get them
from them so if they have the phones
they can get it from that and if they're
in the server they can get it from that
now the question is why did they respond
that way why did they respond with this
technical glitch and I have some new
news Sean I have been told by members in
Congress that they will release that
memo that they will not be capped not
going to be bullied - yeah they're not
going to be bullied by the DOJ they want
this memo out to the public and they
will go to a vote on this okay Gregg
Jarrett let's talk about first of all
this is a big news about the release of
this but we take it even a step further
I mean you see more text from Lisa Paige
and Peter struck what are your thoughts
50,000 texts if you extrapolate that
that's 68 texts a day did these two
cheating lovebirds who are still married
as other people at the time have any
opportunity to actually do their jobs at
the FBI
it appears abundantly clear that they
harbored an anti-trump animus and a
unabashed adoration for Hillary Clinton
that it influenced their decisions and
they were involved in clearing Hillary
Clinton and launching an investigation
against a political candidate Donald
Trump and then using a false document to
spy on him which is an abuse of power -
felony crime ten years punishable behind
bars
and now you've got the DOJ trying to
cover up the four-page Intel memo as
Nixon once famously said it's not the
crime it's the cover-up well with these
guys
it's both crimes in government let's go
to this this new development Sara you
caught this and it was in your article
tonight on Sarah Carter calm but Jason
Chavez the idea that well if the
investigation leads to impeachment
there's no there there I hate the
president he you know f him but if I can
get rid of them and this will make
history well maybe I should get involved
what do you think sweetheart pretty much
what he was saying to his lover but look
Shawn I think you gave the best in
opposites of what's happening here the
only thing I would actually add to it is
there's a National Review article up now
talking about the Nexus to the President
Barack Obama himself when he's
communicating under an alias using an
account that wasn't a dot-com account to
a Hillary Clinton who may have been
overseas perhaps in Russia again on a
non secure line then I got to tell you
there's there's an the you know what was
the motive to make sure that Hillary
Clinton was never prosecuted you got to
also explore that and and that's not
experience either congressman in all
your years in Congress do you ever have
an exoneration before investigation no
let's start now me come on there was
something like 16 people that had not
yet been interview 17 and Hillary it's
just unbelievable if a judge had started
writing his opinion before they heard
all the testimony on this come on that
and it's John Ratcliffe under oath
asking director Comey did when did you
make this decision
that's where commis strongest legal
troubles generally about to you because
you reported on this now there's no
there there on that Russia thing but if
this can be his stark if just
impeachment I hate he's low so f him
that's what they wrote each other well
maybe then I should get involved no wait
but you got struck and call me writing
the exoneration then you got the the
insurance policy with paid struck in
McCabe
why are these people still working why
have they not been fired and what impact
is it why didn't mother pick all of
these people and I didn't even mention
Andrew Weissman yet that's right
and what that is one of the biggest
questions right now from former FBI
folks who say look had we even done a
little a little speck of what these
folks did we would be fired we would be
removed what's going on here what's
going on in the seventh floor we can't
get any answers from the FBI why would
the FBI put a guy who was having an
affair this is a counterintelligence
Peter struck was working
counterintelligence he's having an
affair he's texting on an unsecured line
his government issued phone open for
anyone to capture it and then they move
him to human resources they move him
from out of the special counsel and then
into human resources and we can't get an
answer as to why he hasn't been fired
why Lisa page is still working so
there's a lot of questions here we have
to look at deputy director Andrew McCabe
and look at everything that's come out
about Andrew Weissman on the special
counsel Sean there is a continuing
investigation this is the reason why the
DOJ doesn't want this vice a memo out
this is the reason why people are so
tight-lipped about this there needs to
be further investigation into this and I
agree with Chaffetz on this I want it
today and it's not new news that they're
gonna want to talk to Donald Trump it's
not even it's old news all Steve Bannon
is talking that's old news too didn't
these leaks don't you suspect as I do
this came right from Robert Muller's
office because they are under fire and
because of all that we're discovering
here they know their time is up it's not
unusual for a Special Counsel to
interview the subject of the
investigation Donald Trump Trump can't
hide behind executive privilege because
that only applies to protecting your
communications to Congress this is a
criminal investigation the president
could be hauled in front of a grand jury
so Trump has to respond and testify the
only question is can he limit the scope
of it which is attorneys should try to
do because
as you know I was a defense attorney I
have yet to meet a prosecutor who cares
a whit about justice in fairness they
care about convictions and indictments
they're one lost column so this could be
a perjury trap an obstruction trap the
president needs to be careful about that
but he's a smart guy and when he needs
to be I've read his depositions he can
be very focused and cogent would you
have ever let the President on Io I
appreciate he wants to be upfront honest
I would never in a million years never
ever ever allow him to go before this
witch-hunt Special Counsel but he has no
choice you can't invoke executive
privilege in a situation like this it's
a legitimate criminal investigators
enough legitimate reasons of a bias and
an abuse within the special counsel that
he has legitimate legal arguments hello
yeah by meeting with Muller you are in a
way legitimizing his investigation which
is illegitimate under the special
counsel law there has to be a stated
crime look at the order signed by rod
Rosenstein to Muller
there's no stated crime it's an illegal
investigation but the President may have
no choice
let's get your take on this jason
Chaffetz congressman
I wouldn't in a million years I would
fight that up to the Supreme Court on
the grounds that number one Muller's
team is corrupt that it was founded
remember Hillary rigged the primary
Hillary paid for the phony dossier
Hillary got a pass when she committed
felonies by people that even were
involved in the investigation especially
Peter struck and Peter struck and call
me and call me set it up using
information he never should have
revealed then the phoney dossier was a
predicate to get the FISA warrant
against the president I don't think
there's I believe anybody liberal
conservative Republican Democrats civil
libertarian you've got to be concerned
about the abuse of intelligence and the
misuse of our intelligence and
weaponizing against the American people
look I think I would do
what you suggested and not do it but I
tell you what Donald Trump is unlike
anybody I've ever seen before and I
think he wants to get out there and do
that and if you look at what Donald
Trump jr. did he released all his emails
he gave 23 hours of testimony about a 20
minute meeting they do things different
one last thing I got to add Shawn though
with struck in Page why do these people
have security clearances if you don't
have a security clearance guess what you
don't work at the Department of Justice
in their capacity so well how can they
possibly have a security clearance take
away that security clearance and get rid
of them they should be fired they
shouldn't be working and being paid by
the American taxpayers right now all
right Sarah card we're gonna give you
the last word this segment well I can
just tell you this I spoke with a
defense attorney who's very familiar
with Andrew Weissman and Robert Moeller
and he said the president would have to
be crazy to fall into their trap this is
what they do this is what they've done
in the past
they're gonna try to find anything and
this is why they want to question him so
Sean I mean I don't know the legalese
here Greg is the expert but that's what
I was told
all right cool last word for you Greg
jarred yeah I wish there was a way the
president could try to avoid it Bill
Clinton tried his best not to talk to
Ken Starr he negotiated some limits on
his taped interview but in the end he
had to do it there's just as no legal
basis I mean try to go to the Supreme
Court Supreme Court is gonna knock you
down politically it's gonna be ugly for
the president he's got to do the
interview he's got to do the interview
but there's a precedent for restrictions
is a precedent for what the topics are
going to be a Bill Clinton case proffer
all sorts of okay lawyers they get in
other words these can't be open-ended
Greg it's impossible right limit the
scope
I'll just go you know and by the way
from the president's point of view it's
quite simple I didn't talk to any
Russians I didn't collude in terms of
obstruction of justice I'm allowed to
fire people in the executive branch all
right thank you appreciate it as always
Greg Sarah congressman thank you all for
joining us now the